>>Quin: My name is Quin and I live
on the Central Coast of California.
I really like to do embedded
electronics, soldering, hacking,
3-D print ing and laser-cutting.
It's really cool seeing
your project come to life.
I used to do a lot of LEGO
stuff, like taking things apart,
and a computer is something
that you can easily take apart
and sometimes not as
easily put it back together.
And so I got an interest in that
and I went to the Maker Faire
in San Mateo in 2011 with my dad
and so there I got my first Arduino.
This is the Arduino.
This is the main board, the Uno
and this is the Make
Edition for the Maker Faires.
>>So here I'm using my phone and
when I text it a certain command,
like "LED ON", then it
goes through the Internet
and comes back to the Arduino.
>>The main thing that's special
about this is that you can program it
to do whatever you'd like.
You can attach sensors,
such as light sensors,
and attach it also to LEDs or motors.
Everything's open-source, which
means you can get everything
for free online and one-by-one I
went online and looked at tutorials
and that's how I learned.
>>This a WeevilEye kit.
I used a soldering iron and
some solder to solder the kit
and basically solder is electric glue
and so I bond the circuits
together using the solder
and thus the wires would be
connected inside this board.
This could be used as a nightlight.
So when the room is darker
then the lights would turn on,
and as it went darker then
the lights would be brighter.
>>James Hogeboom: Well, I didn't know
anything about the maker movement
until I heard about
Quin and it's pretty fun
when you have a gem right
there in your own district.
It's pretty cool to have a
student who's that curious and that
into learning on his own, basically.
>>Quin: This is filament.
This is a soldering iron.
This is a Leatherman.
These are solder supplies.
These are breadboards.
These are Arduinos.
And this is my 3-D printed logo.
>>James Hogeboom: Quin came to
one of our school board meetings
and he talked to the school board
about what he does with Arduinos
and all those circuit
boards and things
and really gave us his
thoughts on how we need
to be more engaging
as a school district.
>>Quin: The 3-D printer that
I have is called a Bukobot.
>>So here's the filament and
it's basically a spool of plastic
and it has the spool holder, too.
It goes all the way down into here
and this is the main extruder part
and so basically it melts it and
it spits it out in the nozzle.
This axis is the X-axis,
so it moves side to side.
This is the Y, and right here
and right here are the Z-axis
and so these move up and down.
First, you take your 3-D
model from Tinkercad.com
and download it into
your host program.
Then you slice it using
the program called "Slicer"
and this basically turns the 3-D
model code into 3-D printer code.
And so the 3-D printer code
is basically a set of X,
Y and Z coordinates that my
computer tells the 3-D printer to do.
Layer by layer it prints a
3-D object with filament.
>>James Hogeboom: The power I think
of the maker movement is
they're really focused
on building something
that they think is cool.
They're not like, "Well,
here's our math problem.
You need to learn it."
No, "Here's a cool project and
I want to build that project.
Oh, and by the way I need
to learn about electricity
and then engineering principles."
They're learning all
these STEM kinds of things
that are gonna be helpful
to them later on.
But they're learning
it in the context
of something that's fun
and interesting to them.
>>Quin: The hacker space I was
teaching my friends how to solder
as well as teaching them how to
use the Tinkercad.com software
to design their own key
chain and 3-D print it.
>>Click on the box and change
the one that goes up and down
to five or actually to three.
>>I really like to teach other
people how to do embedded electronics
in the Arduino and stuff like that,
because once I teach them they
can teach some of their friends
and that overall makes
the maker community bigger
and everybody can help each other.
>>Is it working?
Yeah.
>>Student: So I've noticed it
looks like that thing always stays
in the same place and then that
board moves around a little bit.
>>Quin: Yeah, exactly.
So the X-axis is like that, Y
is like that and then Z is--
>>Dale Dougherty: I'm
interested in this idea
of Maker spaces finding
their way into schools
and transforming a number of things.
You know, the art studio
connected to the computer lab,
connected to the shop class,
connected to the biotech lab,
but the difference is instead of
directing students to do things,
you're inviting them to
create things and make things.
>>James Hogeboom: The self-confidence
and sense of self-efficacy
that I think students get from
creating their own projects
and seeing them be successful
and seeing that they can do it,
that I think is so powerful.
>>Dale Dougherty: We are defined
very much by our culture as consumers
and we're users in that
sense and what I'm trying
to really effect is a
transition from that mindset
to one where you're a maker.
The world around me isn't just
something that was built for my use.
It's something that
I need to contribute
to and I could change that.
If something isn't the way it should
be I have the power and the sense
of control to be able to do that.
>>Quin: I look at everything
a lot differently now
because now I can see what's
in every electronic product,
what's in a smart phone, every
component in it, as well as what's
in a computer, but other things
such as skateboards, bicycles,
I could see different ways
on how to make it better
so that other people could
iterate on that design.